يوميا وعلى مر الشهور السته الماضيه تضطر
ليليا الى التردد على مراكز توزيع المياه
التي اقامتها وزاره الطوارئ في مختلف
ارجاء المدينه فمره واحده كل ثلاثه ايام
فقط تضخ السلطات المياه لسكان المدينه
لمده لا تزيد على ساعتين وغالبا ما تصل
فقط الطوابق السفلى من المباني فيما تبقى
عشرات المدن والقرى لاسيما المتاخمه لخط
الجبهه محرومه من المياه بشكل كامل
هكذا اضطر يوميا الى تنظيف الاواني بالطبع
جلبها يشكل صعوبه كبيره احمل عشرات
الجالونات من المياه
في كل يد من الصعب جدا حملها حتى الطابق
السادس
ظهري لم يعد يتحمل نشفق على المسنين الذين
بقوا وحدهم
نساعدهم قدر الامكان لكن الامر صعب للغايه
تفاقمت ازمه المياه في دانيتك مع احتدام
المعارك وقصف المحطات تنقيه وضخ المياه في
المنطقه وتعطيل امدادات قناه
التي تعد عصب الحياه في المنطقه
بسبب الاضرار التي تعرضت لها مرافق
وامدادات المياه ووقف عمل القناه بتنا
نحصل على كميه محدوده من المياه مدينه
دونيتسك وحدها تحصل على خمس ما تحتاجه
تخيلوا حجم الصعوبات التي تقف امامنا
تبقى الاولويه حاليا للمستشفيات والمؤسسات
الطبيه التي تحاول السلطات المحليه ضمان
تزويدها بالمياه فيما يعاني البقيه
للتقليل من وطاه هذه الازمه على حياه
السكان بدا مجمع البناء العسكري التابع
لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه الشهر الماضي
بتشييد قناه مائيه تصل مياه نهر الدون
بقناه
يتوقع ان تضخ نحو 300 الف متر مكعب من
المياه يوميا للمنطقه
يعمل حاليا نحو 2500 شخص على قدم الوساق
لبناء هذه القناه في اسرع وقت ممكن اذ
تعول السلطات على اتمام تشييدها بحلول شهر
ابريل المقبل لكن ذلك يبقى حلا جزئيا فما
تحتاج اليه المنطقه من المياه يقدر بنحو
مليون متر مكعب كانت تحصل عليها من منابع
المياه الخاضعه لسيطره اوكرانيا في شمال
دانيتك ومقاطعه خاركيف لذلك تقول السلطات
ان الحل يكمن في السيطره على هذه المناطق
الجزيره دانيسك